So today it's again a brand new topic.
So if you like at relativity,
you would be in grief and mourning.
If it got to be really nasty, you will
be relieved that that's behind us. Now,
and let me remind you one more time
that the problem set for relativity was
quite challenging because I had to make
up most of the problems and they're not
from the book.
So that a little more difficult.
The exam will be much more
lenient compared to the
homework that generally true,
but particularly true in this case.
Okay,
so today I'm going to introduce
you to some mathematical tricks.
As you probably noticed by now,
a lot of physics has to do with the
mathematics and if you're not good in one,
you're not going to be good in the other.
And I just thought I'd spend some time
introducing you to some tricks of the
trade and then we will start using that
first important trick is to know what's
called Taylor series.
Okay. I see this as greeted by
a booze and the hissing sounds.
I'm not sure
what your past experience with Taylor's
city's water is and why it leaves you so
scarred. And uh, I'm happy.
My experience with Taylor's
thesis in positively positive,
and I don't think I can carry on any of
my things that not only the Taylor cds,
but I'll tell it to you Taylor cities as
we guys in the physics department tend
to use it.
The philosophy of the
Taylor's CDs is the following.
That is some function f of X.
And I'm going to drive that function,
something like this.
But I'm going to imagine that you don't
have access to the whole function.
You cannot see the whole thing.
Uh,
you can only zero in on a
tiny region around here.
And the question is,
as you try to approximate as you try
to build on a good approximation to the
function, oh, how will you set it up
so that you can write an approximation,
but this whole function valid near
the point x equals zero where you know
something.
So suppose I block out the whole function.
You've got mind and mental.
I don't show you anything except
what's happening here. Now that works.
I show you only f of zero.
That's all you had told.
The value of the function is 92
what should we do away from Mexico?
Zero.
Well,
you got no information about this function
or you don't know if it's going up.
If it's going down. All I tell you is
one number what is doing. Now it's clear.
The best approximation you
can make is a flat line.
There's no reason to tilted one way or
the other given the information you have.
So the first approximation, the function
you will say is ffx equal to that.
It's not equal to.
You can put some symbol or that
means approximately equal to,
yeah,
but then if you have, it's like saying
temperature, today's mighty to at,
what's it going to be tomorrow?
Well,
if you don't have anything else,
you cannot tell what is
going to be tomorrow.
But if you know that this is fall and
the temperature's always going down and
somebody tells you,
I know the rate of change of temperature,
I know that as a up to date.
The rate of change of
temperature is something that
you can use that information
to make a prediction on
what it'll be tomorrow.
That is to say for values of x,
not equal to zero,
and let's denote by the
this falling symbol.
F prime of zero is the derivative,
which is the FDX at x equals zero and
you would multiplied by x and that's your
best bet for what the function
is away from Mexico zero.
What that does is to approximate the
function by a straight line with the right
intercept and the right slope by right,
I mean Matt says what you
know about the exact function
and if it turns out the function really
was the straight line, you're done.
It's not even an approximation.
It'll track the function all
the way through eternity,
but it can happen of course,
that the function besides to curve
upwards as I've shown in this example,
and this will not work if
you go too far for a while,
you will be tangent to the function,
but then it'll bend away from you.
So it's really good for very
small acts and you can say, well,
I want to do a little better
when I go for the road. Well,
what does doesn't tell you
this approximation is that
the rate of change itself
has the rate of change.
This assumes the rate of change
is a fixed date of change,
which is the rate of change at the origin
and the rate of change of the rate of
change is the second date of it.
So if somebody told you, look,
here's one more piece of information,
I know the second day of it to go the
function which I'm going to write this f
double prime at zero,
what would that information,
you can build a better approximation to
the function and you will put that in x
square.
But the key thing is you
got to divide by two art.
If you like two factorial,
where do you d divide
by the two factorial?
Because your goal is to
take this approximation and
make sure it has whatever
you know about the function built into it,
right?
Let's check this approximation and
see if it satisfies those properties.
First of all at x equals zero let's
compare the two sites at x equals zero.
The lefthand side is f of
zero on the right hand side.
When you put x equals zero you kill
this and you kill this and it matches,
so you certainly got the right
value of the function. Then you say,
what if it take the data to have the
function at x equals zero let's take the
data to up this try and function are the
approximate function on both sides and
I take the derivative that being
a constant that's not contribute.
This didn't ever do have xs one.
Okay.
In the next one they'd ever,
two x squared is two x two x cancels the
two so I get amped double prime of zero
times x but now evaluate the
deliberative at x equal to zero.
Then that gets rid of this guy and the
date of it to all my test function.
Matt is the deliberate to what the actual
function because this is the actual
little bit about the actual function.
Yeah,
that what follows that.
If you want to say,
how about the second day they
went have this function, uh,
let's take the test function I
have or the approximation, take it,
second date of it too and make
sure that comes out right.
I don't feel like writing this out,
but try to do this in your head.
Take to deliver to them the lefthand side
and see what happens on the right hand
side. Well if you take one day
to rid of this guy is gone.
If you take two derivative,
this guy gone.
And then if you take the first
day they have a TV, you get to x,
take the second derivative,
you get to the two cancels the two of you,
put x equals zero.
If you do,
you find that f double prime zero here
matches the secondary to go the function
on the left hand side.
So this two factorial is that to make
sure that the function you have cooked up
has the right value of the function,
that the origin has the right slope at
the origin as the right rate of change of
the slope at the artist. Well,
it's very clear what we should do.
If you had a whole bunch of derivatives
than the approximation we will write
will look like f entity limited.
I'm cannot Dora and primes there.
So and means and sets primes extra the
end over end factorial and you go as far
as you can. If you know 13
derivatives, put 13 derivatives here,
that's an approximation.
That's not called a tailor cities.
That's the approximation to the function.
Now it may happen that sometimes we
hit the Jackpot and you know all the
derivatives. Someone tells you all the
databases of the function than white stop.
Yes sir,
I had them all up.
Then you will get the sum going from
the zero did ever do all the way up to
infinity. And if you do the
summation at every value of x,
you get a value.
And if that summation is meaningful
and gives you a finite number,
that in fact is exactly
the function you are given.
That is the tailor series.
Tailor cds is a serious with
infinite number of terms,
which if you sum up and sum
up to something sensible
will actually be as good as
the left side.
So let me give you one example.
It's famous example one over one
minus x is the real function.
Okay? You and I know this function. We
know how to put it in the calculator.
We know how to plot it. You gave me an
accent and I stick it to the denominator,
subtracted from one inverted.
That's the function.
But instead suppose this function was
reveal to us in status we a trolled f of
zero.
What does F of zero here put?
X Equals Zero F of zero is one.
Now let's take the date of it
to have this function. The FDX,
the FDX has a minus one because it's one
minus x to the minus one times square
than they did the data do with what's
inside this. That gives you a minus one.
This is simple calculus. How to take
delivery to have this fella here,
having taken the date of it,
evaluated at x equals zero this vanishes.
That becomes one and you get one.
If you're not, take the second
bit of it to have dysfunction,
which I don't feel like doing
and I evaluate that at x equals zero and
I'll find it as equal to two factorial.
In fact, I'll find the date of it
to at the origin to be n factorial.
Well that's very nice because then
my approximation to the
function begins as one
plus x times the first derivative,
which happens to be one plus
x squared over two factorial.
Time to secondary we'll do it happens
to be two factorial plus x cubed over
three factorial times three factorial.
So you can see,
but this guy is going,
it looks like one plus x plus x squared,
et Cetera.
The Taylor series is
infinite sound in practice.
You may be happy to just
keep a couple of terms,
so let's get a feeling for what does
a couple of times can do for us.
So let me take a x equal a 0.1
x equaled a 0.1.
The real answer is one over one minus
0.1 which is one over 0.9 which is 1.1111
et cetera.
That's that's the target.
What do you do with the series?
The city starts at one time to one 10th
plus one over a hundred plus one over a
thousand and so on. And you can
see as I keep more and more terms,
I keep this filling up.
These ones,
if you stopped with one over a
thousand you stop right there.
So this is the exact answer.
This is the approximation,
but it's clear to you perhaps the simple
example that if you kept all the terms
in the series, you really will get
this infinite number of recurring ones.
So that is the function that
is a tailor approximation,
which is chop it off and I where you
want and there's a good approximation.
And does the Taylor series the
cities means some everything.
Now something an infinite number of
numbers. Is that the delicate issue?
I don't want to go there at all.
I discuss that in this math book,
but sometimes there's some makes no
sense. Then you got to quit. But example,
put x equal two to
the connect function as one minus two.
This minus one
I would approximation for next x equal
do to look like one plus two plus four
plus a what?
Eight and first of all this some is
going to grow to infinity because the
numbers are getting bigger and bigger.
This some seems to be all positive,
but it's a correct dancers. Negative.
Obviously the is doesn't work.
So the next lesson about Taylor cds is
you can write down the cities but it may
not sum up to anything sensible
beyond a certain range.
So if you're doing the Taylor series at
x equals zero and you go to x equal to
two, it just doesn't work. So you can
ask how far can I go from the origin?
Well,
in this simple example,
we know that a at x equal to one
the function just going to infinity.
That's why you couldn't go there and
you cannot go to the right hand side of
that point. The function is well
defined on the other side, but this cds,
there's knowledge that the function here,
it's not enough to get
you on the other side.
So this is a case where that are
obvious problems that x equaled the one.
But if I wrote a function like one or one
plus x square, that's a nice function,
got no troubles anywhere. And yet
if you took the sailors cds for it,
you will find if you go beyond
absolute value of x equal to one,
the cds makes no sense.
So I don't want to do that
mathematical theory of series.
I just want to tell you that functions
can be approximated by series and if
you're lucky or you can do the whole
psalm if you know all the data motives and
the whole sum maybe converge to
give a final answer in with guests,
it's as good as the function.
One guy can use one over one minus x,
the other one can use the infinity
cities and Marilee and mathematically and
every sin equal as long as they're known,
stray outside the region or
validity of the infinite series.
Okay. So, uh,
the most popular example that I've been
using in the class you'd remember is one
plus x to the end.
That's the function we can do it
staler series f of zero is one
what's the date? Two of the function. It's
n times one plus extra the n minus one,
right?
The FDX
is n times one plus extra.
The n minus one.
If I had evaluated at x equals zero.
It just an that's why we get this famous
result we've been using all the time.
If x is small enough,
you stopped it because the next time
is going to involve an x squared in the
next cube. And if x is tiny, we have
no respect for x squared and x cube.
We just cut it off.
But if you want an extra one of you guys,
you want to ask me what happens next?
We'll take the second derivative.
You can see n times n minus one times
one plus actually the n minus two if you
put x equals zero n times
n minus one x squared.
And don't forget the two factorial.
So what I've been doing is
I've been saying one plus
extra the end approximately
equal to this, but even if you
keep that as still approximate,
but it's a good approximation.
How many terms you want to
keep depends on how tiny exes.
Okay, so it's good to know
that's an infinite series,
but it's also good to know you can chop
it off and do business with a few terms.
In fact,
all of the activity we reduced as follows,
the energy of a particle is this,
which we can write it as MC squared times
one minus B squared over c squared or
the minus one half.
If you expand this in a power cds,
you're going to get mc square plus one
half MV squared plus stuff involving B to
the fourth oversee to the
fourth times the square.
We dropped all this and for 300 years we
did mechanics keeping just this stroke
just kept that first non trivial
Terman all of our collisions and so on.
But we did just only that
up to that point. So,
so the approximations that video useful
and they described nature approximately.
If you say, well, I want to be
exact, you can go back and use this.
Unfortunately general relativity tells
you that that's not exactly that in
quantum mechanics still to
the whole thing is wrong.
So at every stage you will
have to give up something.
So I have a lot of respect
for approximations. If you
could not describe the,
well approximately you couldn't have come
where you've come because no one knows
the exact answer to a single question.
You can post asked me a question
and the answer is I don't know.
Second part,
the answer is nobody knows.
Because if your questions is give
an answer to arbitrary position,
any question to ask,
we just don't know.
Newtonian mechanics works
for small velocities. Uh,
all of the mechanics worked for any
velocity but not for very tiny objects.
Then you got to use quantum mechanics.
So always,
uh, theories get way the new theories.
And so approximations are very important.
So you have to learn this.
Okay,
so now I'm going to consider
the following function.
E to the X.
No, this guy is something you all know
and love because it's one nice thing about
the function is every
database is e to the x, right?
Every child knows you're the has got
e to the x assets didn't have it.
Why do we like that here?
That means all the bit of actives
are sitting in front of you.
They're eat the x and an x equals
zero e to the zero is one so every
deliberative is one. Then the
function is very easy to write down.
It is really one less x plus
x squared over two factorial.
Let's extra the three over two factorial
x the four over four factorial.
You can go on like this and if you like
to write use the compact notation is
extra.
The n o n n factorial and going from
zero to infinity at zero factorial is
defined to be one
actually e to the x.
If you ever forget the value of e
and I need to know the value of e because
when I locked my suitcase and check it
into the airport,
I use either e or Pi because they are
the only two numbers I can remember.
So if I forget the value of e,
I just say he is the same as the one.
I got one plus one plus one
over two dozen, one over six.
And pretty soon I'm telling the guy
scanning my luggage. That's my code.
And it's much better than any other
court because I cannot reconstruct, uh,
say my grandfather's name and
not get it right out in Minot,
construct my house at rest, at my
phone at risk. This doesn't change.
I've been moving it on all over the world.
This is a very reliable number.
No Pie is a good number,
but rule for computing pyre somewhat
more difficult by also can be computed as
an infinite series.
But this guy is very easy.
There's 2.77 something that is he okay
now he had a very nice property of the
cds.
It is good for any x.
You remember the CDs for one old,
one minus x,
crashed and burned at x equal to one.
This seat is always good.
You put x equals 37 million,
you got 37 million,
37 million cube. There's a million.
The fourth power, don't worry.
These factorials downstairs will tame
it down and make it converge and we'll
give you either the
whatever number I gave.
That's something I'm not
proving what the seed is.
Put either the ex no limits on validity.
All right?
Then we take the function course,
sign x,
of course I next we all
know and love is this guy.
Okay,
has got a period of two Pi,
but we can write a cities for it because
it's a function and what do I need to
know to write the cities for it?
I need to know the value of
the function or the origin.
So we know coastline of zero is one.
If you take the date of it,
dude,
you get minus sign and
it's value of zero is zero.
You take the one more derivative,
you can minus go signed zero,
which is minus one. And I think
by, and I have, you get the point.
Every other director will vanish
at the remaining delivered to,
so we'll alternate and
sign from one to minus one.
That means if you crank it out,
you will get one.
You won't have anything linear in x
because the Coefficient of that is signed
zero with vanishes.
Then you will get x squared over two
factorial plus actually the four over four
factorial and so on.
Okay.
The Cisco sine x,
if you cut it off after
some number of terms,
it's not going to work in the beginning.
One minus x squared looks very good.
This is one minus x squared
over to look like this,
but eventually this approximation will
go bad on you because x to the fourth is
just x to the fourth
and grow without limit.
No one's telling you this approximation
has a property that coastline is less
than one.
It doesn't satisfy that because you're
not supposed to use it that far out,
but if you keep all the terms and in
fact even though the exit the fort is
taking off, x to the minus six is saying,
hey, come down x date. The saying go up,
you add them all together. Remarkably
you would reproduce this function.
Yeah,
that he hard to imagine that the coastline
that we know as Oscillatory is really
this function
and I hope all of you know enough
to know how to find the series.
You should know the date of it too.
Of course sign is minus sign.
I did have two of sinus sign
and evaluate them or the origin.
I say you can build up the series then
if it was similar tricks for sine x sine
of zero zero did a,
we have scientists course sine and cosine
of zero is one so the first day of it
was one that gives you this term.
Next one. One. Give me anything.
The one after that we'll
give you this and that.
This guy would go on like this one.
Okay.
Okay,
so these have CDs for e to the x cost
say annex and Synnex good for all x so
there's no restriction on this.
One of the really interesting things
to do when you are bored are stranded
somewhere and the airport is the
Taiko sine squared plus science square
squared, the whole thing at the square
of the whole thing and add them up.
You will find by miracle you will
get the one from the squaring,
the one and every other power of XL.
Keep on vantage.
Of course you will have to collect
powers of x by expanding the bracket,
but it will all counsel.
That's what I meant by saying this
series is as good as this function.
It'll be all the identities.
No.
Okay. Now for the
punchline thing, everyone,
some of you may know what the punchline
is. The punchline is the following.
Let us introduce without any preamble.
Right now the number I,
what's the square root of minus one?
All I expected. Why is that?
When I squatted I get minus one
if I cubit.
ICUBED is ice squared times eyes,
so that's minus eye.
An eye to the fourth is back to plus one
cause I the fourth.
This ice square times I
swear and I squared is minus
one so you could take power
survive. She'll keep jumping
between these values. It'll be,
I will become minus one. It'll become
minus side and become plus one.
That's the set of possible
values for power supply.
It'll be one of these four values.
Well then we are told
if you now consider the
following rather strange objects,
he put the I x
o x.
You have to agree is really bizarre.
He is some number.
You want to raise it to two that's fine.
Number of times number I
s a strange number, right?
It's this waiter to minus one and you
wanted me to raise e do a complex power.
What does that even mean?
Multiply e by itself. I x times.
Well that definition of powers is
no good, but the cts, what he did,
the x defines it for all x.
Then we boldly defined e to the x or
even complex values of x as simply this
thing. To the IMX plugged
in, place her bags,
and by that fashion be
defined exponentially.
So the exponential function
is simply defined as subway,
right?
He raised two dog used to dog one dog,
the dog squared over two,
that's the e raised to anything
is a cord for this series.
And now we raised it to barriers, things,
real numbers, complex numbers, matrices,
whatever you want your pet,
you can put that up.
Of course you got to be really careful.
You cannot raise erased the dog
because the units don't match.
There's a dog here and dogs quit.
So you should have divided
by some standard dog,
like the president is doc, take some
standard, but Napoleon's dog divided,
then you've got something dimensionless,
then it will work.
So as long as a, that is some dimensional,
this object, this is what we mean.
But he raised with that Mattson.
Fantastic. Uh, leap of imagination.
Hope to raise, eat whatever power
you like. Take the city as well.
Let's do the series.
Okay,
so I'm going to get one plus x
plus x squared over two factorial.
That's I x cubed over three factorial.
And I'm going to stop after
this last term. I actually,
the Ford over four factorial.
Keep going. Then what do you get?
Let's take the one from here. Uh,
leave this alone for a minute.
You're right.
I times x go here.
I squared is minus one.
So I get minus x squared over
two factorial than I come here.
ICUBED is minus I.
So I right here minus x
cubed over two factorial.
Then I go back here and write
extra foretold four factorial.
By now everybody knows what's going on.
Everybody knows that this is just
of course INX less ice sign next.
Okay.
This is a super duper formula.
Life cannot go on without this. You want
to draw a box around it. This one, uh,
dry because without this formula
we cannot do so many things we do.
It says that the techno metric functions
and the exponential functions that
actually very intimately connected and
he did all defined by the poverty cities.
You can able, you're able to prove this.
So this is the formula proven by oiler
and it's considered
very beautiful formula.
And here is the particularly beautiful
special case of this formula.
If you put x equals two Pi,
I get that it's an e to
the IPI equal the cost pie,
which is minus one plus I
signed pie with the zero.
So I get the result either the
IPI plus one equal to zero.
No,
everybody agrees.
This has gotta be one of
the most beautiful formulas
you can imagine involving
numbers are in mathematics.
Why is it such a great formula?
Look at this formula here.
Pi defined from the Egyptian times to
the ratio of circle to diameter I squared
or the minus one one is
the basis for all integers.
E is the basis for the logarithm.
Here's a formula in which all the key
numbers appeared in one single compact
formula.
So people think this and the fact that
these numbers would have a relation at
all is staggering and this is
the nature of the relationship.
This is voted Deimos formula most
likely to be remembered as formula.
Now we are going to use
not only the special case,
but we're going to use this all the time.
So you guys have to tell how
many people have seen this.
Okay.
If you have not seen this,
then you've got more work than
people who have seen this.
You got to go and you got to do all the
intermediate steps so you get used to
this thing.
Now let's do the following two other
variations and then I'll move on.
If I change extra minor sex,
then I get either the minus
I x cost center minus x is
course sine x and sign of
minus X is minus sine x so I
can get that to the relation.
Then I'm going to combine
those two to do the following.
I'm going to say that course x is equal
to eat the I x e to the minus x over to.
You can check that
and sign x is equal to eat the I x
minus e to the minus IEX over to I.
Yeah,
you just add and subtract these
two formulas and you get that.
Okay, so what does this mean? It
means a took not metric functions.
You don't need them.
You've got exponential functions.
You can manufacture trigonomic
function out of them.
Provided you're not afraid to go to
exponents with complex number I in them
and all the identities you know about
science and coastlines will follow from
this. For example, if they call
sign square plus Science Square,
you're supposed to get one where
they can square the right hand side.
You can square the lefthand side and you
will get one to get the one you bet to
the member of the following. Either the
IMX names, either the minus IEX is what
you don't have.
You come by and exponents.
You raised it to one power times the same
thing. Relation other power is erase.
Do I? X minus x either
is to zero, which is one.
When you raise that number to a power,
you multiplied by the number
of times a different power.
The product is the number two,
the sum of the two powers,
right powers combined to queue times
store the fourth store, the sixth.
That's true for two. It's true
for me. It's true for everything.
Exponents ad when you multiply them,
that's why either the IEX and even the
minus sign x combined to give you one.
Once you know that you can prove this.
Okay,
now I'm going to do a little
more of a complex numbers.
Maybe I'll leave this alone for now.
So I introduced you the number I by
saying it's a squared or the minus one and
complex numbers entered our life even
though we didn't go looking for them.
You can write down
equations with real numbers,
with no intentionally and
working anything fancy like this,
and you find that there's no solution
to this equation even though everything
that is completely real
are so you can say, well,
x squared minus one and they can
manufacture a number I with the property I
squared is minus one. Then of course
you can have x equal to plus or minus.
I as your answer.
So complex numbers of errors by
trying to solve a quadratic equations.
So let me write you a slightly more
interesting quadratic equation.
X squared plus x plus one equals zero.
Okay,
so there's no funny business. All real
numbers. We want to solve this equation.
So if we go back to other good old a
sandbox days when we knew what the answer
for this was
a minus three over two
and be already have a problem because we
don't know what to do with square root
of minus three so we will write it as
square root of minus three we'll write it
as square root of minus one times square
root of three squared or than minus one
we will call I and we will say
this equation has two roots
explicit minus one I mean x plus minus
the two routes which are minus one plus
or minus square root of three I over to,
so one root is one minus,
one less rude,
three I over to the other old route is
minus one minus root three over two.
These are solutions
formally to this equation.
In the following sense,
take this x that I'm giving you
what that into that equation,
square the x and IDX. Stuart and I had
the one it'll in fact satisfied equation.
All you will have to know of when you
met it plated is that ice grade is minus
one. We've seen the one property you
can know solve a quadratic equation,
so people realize that if you enlarge
the numbers to include complex numbers,
then you can solve any polynomial
equation with that many number of groups.
If it's quadratic, it'll have two routes
which Kubik you'll have three routes.
They may not all be real.
They may involve the complex number nine.
Yeah,
no, very important point to
notice is that this whole thing
minus one plus root three I over to the
whole thing is a single complex number.
Don't think of it to some of two numbers.
It's a single complex number.
For example,
if this had been plus instead of minus,
you'd get something like one plus or
minus root three over to take the positive
route. You don't think of it as two
numbers. This is a single number
and that continues to be true
even if it's a complex number.
So you should think of
the whole combination as a
single entity which you can
add to other such entities and squared.
And so on.
Okay,
so that's what we are going to do.
Now we're going to generalize
this particular case and
introduce now a complex
numberZ and we're going to write every
complex numberZ as a part that is no I in
it and a part that has an I
in the example I had here,
x is equal to,
in this example x was minus one over two
and why was a plus or minus root three
over two?
Yeah,
and we are going to visualize that
complex as a point in the x y play.
We just met at x
horizontally and vertically.
Put a dot there that
your complex number z.
Then we say a new complex number called
Z star and it's defined to be x minus I
why?
It's called the complex conjugate
complex conjugate of z is
obtained by changing the sign of,
I say feel like if z is sitting here is
he started sitting there reflected on
the x axis.
Okay,
so how does one work with complex numbers?
You add them, you subtract them, your
new, multiply them and you divide them.
If you know how to do that,
you can do with complex numbers.
Everything you did with real numbers,
so if z one is a complex number
that is equal x one plus Iwai one and
z two is a complex number that is x two
plus I white too.
We will define z one plus z two to be x
one plus y one bless I times I'm Saudi x
one plus x two times eight times white,
one plus white too.
If you drop pictures,
then use z one is that number and z two
is that number that [inaudible] really
it's like adding vectors.
This number is z one plus z two
it's exactly like adding vectors,
but you don't think of
this plus that as two disjoint numbers
but as forming a single entity in a
complex number.
Z X is called the real part
of z and there's been ordered by symbol.
Real Dizzy.
If you wanted to get to z, if we want to
get the deal part of a complex numberZ ,
do where there's complex
conjugate and divide by two
because you are adding
explicitly white minus Osi.
Why you get to x and divided by two
you get that. If you want to get
the wife just called imaginary part ofZ ,
Z minus z star divided by two one
it's like saying find the x component
of the vector is what automotive place.
I wake comprehensive vectors. Water
multiply multiplies Jay. Similarly,
a complex number can be broken down at
the part with Israel and the part that
multiplies,
I extract the real part,
add to it the conjugate and divide
by two to extract the imaginary part,
subtract the conjugate and divide by two.
Again,
if you have seen you don't need this,
we haven't seen it.
It may look a little fast, but that's
why I posted on the nords, uh, in the,
on the website chapter five from this
math book, which has got all this stuff.
So you can go home and you can read it.
Okay. The next question is
what is the one times z too?
Now that's very easy to calculate x one
plus I y one x two plus I wipe to just
open out the brackets and the
member I squared is minus one.
That's all you got to do.
Does that gives me x one x two that'll,
let me multiply the Iwai one times the
Iwai too and that gives me minus y one
white too
because I squared is minus one plus I
times x one y two x to y one the Soviet
multiply two complex numbers.
That's something very nice that happens
when you multiply a number Z by its
complex conjugate.
What happens when you
multiply Z by its conjugate?
You are saying take x plus
y multiply by x minus y wife
Oh a plus B times a million is
bs is square minus B square,
but remember these I why?
So when you take the square of that
should keep track of all the signs and you
will find is x squared plus y squared.
We denote that
as this and this thing
is called the modulars.
Okay.
Of Z. It's the length of the complex
number z just given by Pythagoras. Yeah.
You shouldn't have anybody take a
complex number. Multiply by age,
conjugate by its complex kind you get the
result will be a real number equal the
square of the length of the complex number
because I'm going to use that now
to do the last of the manipulations,
which is what does the
one divided by Z too.
How do you divide these
crazy numbers on the top?
I write x one plus Iya one the bottom.
I write x two plus Iwai too.
If I only had x two,
I know how to divide.
It's just the number the way
that bay doing that bakes too,
but I got the sum of these two numbers
in the bottom and you can ask how do you
do the division?
The trick always when you run into
this problem is to multiply the top and
bottom by the complex conjugate of get
up the bottle multiplied by x two minus y
to top and bottom.
Okay?
Then something nice happens.
That denominator because nominated then
becomes extra square plus white you
squared, which is an ordinary real
number. Nothing complex about that.
The numerator, you can open
up the brackets. I don't
know if I want to do that.
I just going to be x one x two plus y one
y two plus I times y one x two minus x
one no, don't worry about all the details.
All it means is if you know how
to multiply two complex numbers,
you can also divide by a complex
number. That's the key point. Why?
Because you've got a complex number,
dinner, not matter, you don't like it.
Multiply the top and bottom by
the complex conjugate of this guy.
The denominator turns
into purely real number.
So this whole thing could
be 36 for example. Well,
we know how to divide the
numerator by 36 right?
X One x two plus y one y two is on number,
maybe nine.
Then you would divide by 36 one forth.
This could be eight times 18
it will be 36 you get Iowa too,
so this number could have been
one fourth less. I over too.
So dividing by complex
number is not a problem.
Okay,
so now
why did I do all that stuff
today about either the IEX,
you're going to see that now the rationale
for going through that math is the
following,
so let's take this complex number
that goes from here to here.
That is explicitly why,
and let's introduce just like
we would for an ordinary vector,
this angle data and that length are
whenever they have a vector, you can talk
about the Cartesian components, x and y,
or we can talk about the length of
the vector and the angle it makes.
Then it's clear that x physical Arco
scientists and why our scientist over data
is now an angle associated with a complex
number which tells you at what angle
is located and art is the
length of the complex numbers.
So it's called a polar
form of the complex number.
Then you can see that
Z, which is x, bless I,
why is it going to our claims go
signed data plus ice signed data,
which you can know, right? This
are fine. Eat the ice data.
That's why we did all that work.
To tell you that a complex number
can be written in this form.
You can either write it as explicit,
why artists audio with the data.
They both talk about the same number
one prox about how much real partner,
how many imaginary part it
has other way of writing.
It talks about how long the vector
is and at what angled it is located
containing the same information so that
od is equal to if the inverse of this
formula is that are just square root
of x squared plus y square and Taito.
Yes, 10 in verse. Why are
would x, in other words,
Stan data y over x.
This is why this is rex.
Okay.
Now the advantage of writing a complex
number in polar form is the following.
Suppose I give you two complex numbers.
Xe One is odd one either
the ITA One and z.
Two is art to eat the
right data to the product.
Z One z two is very easy to calculate
in this form because r one r two
multiplied to give you this and
the exponential is combined.
It's a lot easier to
multiply them in this form.
Then when I multiplied them somebody to
hear see threaded in this Cartesian form.
It's a big mess in polar
formative it easy little list.
If you want to multiply
two numbers multiplied the
lengths to get the length of
the new number and add that angles
to get the angle of the product.
So what I'm telling you is that if z
one looks like this guy with some angle
theta one and z two is that gave with an
angle data to the numberZ one z two has
the length equals the product of these
two langues and an angle equal the sum of
these two angles.
So it will look like that.
Do go from this to that. You multiply
the lengths and you add the angles.
So the polar farm is very well suited
for multiplying and it's even better
suited for dividing. If I
say, give me z one over z two
yeah,
well look, we can all do that
in your head. It's our one,
either the data one divided by
r two either the right data to
the modulus of the new number is just
r one over r two and how broad this eat
the Ita one divided by e to the I data too
dividing by either the [inaudible].
Same as multiplying by either the
minus I Taito. So this is really the,
I did a one minus data's too.
Okay.
So I'm assuming you guys can figure
this part out. One over Edi theater.
It's the same as either the minus I data.
Well,
if you don't mean multiply,
Cross multiply and all I'm telling you
is that one equals the [inaudible],
which you know is true when you combined
the angles. So when you got to the,
I take her downstairs, you can take
it upstairs with the reverse angle.
That's a useful trick. I hope you
will remember that. Useful trick.
So that is one part of this thing that
I wanted to carry in your head because
very, very important. When
you take a complex number,
he's got a length and
it's got a direction.
When you multiply a second
by second complex number,
you're able to do two things at the
same time. You're able to rescale it,
they'd be able to rotate it.
You'd be scaled by the length of second
factor and you rotate by the angle
carried by the second fight.
The fact that two operations are done in
one shot is the reason complex numbers
play an incredibly important role in
physics and certainly in engineering and
mathematical physics.
Okay. Uh, I'm going to now change gears,
but I want to stop a little bit and
answered any questions any of you have.
So how many people have seen
all of this before? I see.
So if you saw something you
saw the whole thing would look,
that's not such a big number.
So I am cognizant of the fact
that not many of you have seen it,
but you will have to go
and learn this today.
I'm going to post the problem set for
this some time in the day so you can start
practicing. Don't weight problems has
nothing to do with next Wednesday.
It has a lot to do with today.
I'm going to ask Santa problem today.
I imagine you're going, uh, breathlessly
you're out your room, not able to wait,
jumping into the problem set and working
it out because that's the only way
you're going to find out what these
things mean. If you've never seen them,
I've seen them before in high school
route taken a math course and you've got
lots of practice then
I'm not talking to you,
but I'm going to use this at some point.
So you should understand complex numbers.
And I'm telling you there are very few
branches of any science where complex
numbers will not be used.
Or You may not believe this now,
but that is true. They make even an
electrical engineer. Absolute must.
I have to solve any kind of differential
equation which cannot occur in biology
and chemistry. That's
a must. So it was very,
very important. All right,
so now I'm going to do,
I'm going back to physics. No, laying
back from mathematics to physics.
And the physics of this topic for today
has to do with something very different
from the past.
So forget all relativity.
Now you're going back to Newtonian days.
Kinetic energy is one half Mv Square.
That's a little difficult to go back and
forget what you learned the other hand.
For some of you it may not be so hard.
If you didn't learn anything,
then you're that much ahead
of the other guys. Okay,
but so I remember now the truth
is that a little cubistic theory,
we're going to go back to Newtonian days
and the reason we do it that way is to
give you something interesting.
A hopefully compared to
what you normally do.
So what were you going to study now
is what's called small oscillations
are simple harmonic motion.
It's a ubiquitous fact that if
he took any mechanical system,
which is in a state of equilibrium and
they give it a little kick, it vibrates.
And if you've got a pillar
ceiling to Florida, hit it
with a hammer. It vibrates.
If you take a gong and he hit,
it also vibrates.
If you gotta a rod hanging from
the ceiling through a pivot,
it's hanging that if you pull it,
it goes back and forth.
The standard example.
Everyone likes to use this.
If you got a particle in a ball,
it's very happy sitting in the bottom.
If you push it up a little bit,
it'll go back and forth
and the example that we are going
to consider is the following.
If you have a mass am connected to a
spring and the spring is not stretched,
our contracted, it's very happy
to be there. That's what I mean.
But equilibrium equilibrium means
the body has all the forces on it,
adding up to zero.
It has no desire to move.
The question is if you give it a
little kick, what'll happen? Well,
there are two situations you can have.
You can have a situation where a
particle is on top of the hill,
let's call unstable equilibrium because
if you give that a kick is going to come
down and now going to turn to you.
That's equilibrium but
unstable equilibrium.
I'm talking about stable equilibrium.
That's because they're
the restoring forces.
If you stray away from the equilibrium,
there are forces bringing you back and
in the case of the mass in spring system,
the force m d two m a
is equal to minus k x.
And what is the equation tells you
is if you're straight to the right,
x is positive.
I love play a force to the left.
Remember this is Emma and this is f f
efforts such that it always sends you back
to your normal position.
So we want to understand the
behavior of such a problem.
You want to solve this problem?
Yeah.
So how do you solve this problem?
Well,
I did it for you long back when they
gave you a typical paradigm for how you
apply Newton's laws.
I gave you this example,
so I'm going to go
through it somewhat fast.
Our job is to find the function x that
satisfies this equation and we would like
to write it as follows.
A D two x over DT square is
equal to minus Omega squared x,
but Omega Square,
it's in shorthand for Omega
is the shorthand for square
root of k or whatever.
By the way, I'm using big x
and small lakes like crazy.
So it's this small likes.
I don't mean anything significant between
this and this. They're all the same.
If you want you can take this.
Pardon me?
Yeah, this is Kay and this guy is
k and other equations do you use,
just follow the lecture today.
These are all the same.
Okay, so don't say what happened there
when he moved from one to the other.
All right, so what did I say we should
do? You can make it a word problem.
Let's say I am looking for a function,
which one I take to derivatives looks
like minus itself exit for this number and
we just saw that today.
The trigonometric functions,
the property that you take to
deliberative, they returned
to miners themselves.
So you can take a guess.
That exit looks like
co-signed t but it won't work.
Then I showed you before so I'm
not going to go through that again.
You could do this.
Yes,
but it was his ex is not in
number is x is a function of time.
If you took this function of time
in fact or basis equation provided,
the Omega that you put in is the
Omega that's in the equation.
Why?
Because tape take two derivatives.
First let me get minus Omega Sine Omega
at the second time you get minus Omega
squared cost and make a tea with me and
says minus Omega squared times the Ux
itself and is whatever you like.
Then I said let's plot this
guy and then you plot this guy.
It looks like this is the amplitude.
What does Omega Well Omega is related
to the time or the frequency of
oscillations as follows.
If I start with the t equals zero where
the x is equal to a how long do I have
to wait till I come back to a,
I think everybody should know
that I have to wait a time.
Capital t so that Omega Times t is too
fine cause that's when the costs and
returns to one.
That means the time that you have
to wait is two Pi over omega.
You can see Omega is two Pi over t
it can also write it as two Pi Times
frequency, but frequency is what
you and I would call frequency.
How many oscillations
that desperate second.
That's the inverse of the time period.
So if you pull a mass and you let it go,
it oscillates with the frequency
we just connected with the
forest constant and the mass.
If the spring is very stiff and Kay's
video, large frequency is very high.
If the mass is very big in the motion
is very sluggish and is diminished.
So all this stuff comes
out of the equation.
One ready to marketable part of the
equation is that you can pick any air you
like.
Think about what that means.
What does the meaning of a is the Amanay
with you pulled it when you let it go,
you are told whether you pull the spring
by one inch Arba tenancies the time it
takes to finish a full back and forth
motion is independent of a this frequency
he has independent they yes,
small.
This d here, here at that. Ah, very good.
That's correct.
So let's be careful the stip t,
this is a particular time capital t.
Yeah,
so that a marketable property of simple
harmonic motion is that the amplitude
does not determine the time period.
If you pull it by two inches compared
to one inch, it's got a long way to go.
But because you pulled it by two inches,
the spring is going to be that much more
cans and it's going to exert a bigger
force so that it'll go faster
for the most of the time.
That's very clear what the fact that it
goes faster than exactly the right way
to complete the trip at the same time
as rather miraculous property up.
The fact that this equation
has this particular form,
if you had tampered with this,
if you add to this a little bit like
one over a hundred times x cubed and all
these bets are off, it's gotta be that
equation for that result to be true.
Okay,
so this is simple harmonic motion.
Then you can do the following variant of
this solution, which I will write down.
Now suppose,
uh,
I set my clock to zero right there.
You set your clock to zero yet,
but I can say, you know what,
I just got up and I'm looking at the mass.
I set my clock to zero.
When it hits zero, it's not at the
maximum, but it's the same physics.
It's the same equation.
And that really comes from the fact that
we had one more latitude here of adding
a certain number, Phi, which is
called the phase the oscillator.
Okay,
whatever you pick, four or
five, the it'll still work.
And what did you pick for
capital aid and still work?
So whenever you have an Oscillator,
namely a mass in spring system,
and you want to know what is
x is going to be at all times,
you need to somehow determine
the amplitude and the fish.
I want you to know that you can
calculate exit all future times.
So let me give you an example.
Suppose an oscillator has x equaled
the five and velocity equals zero,
uh, t equal to zero. What does that mean?
I pulled it by five and then let it go
is I tell you the spring constant care
and I tell you the mass and I said watch
the future of X.
You've got to come back to this equation
and you got to say five equals a course
sine of zero plus fi and
how about the velocity?
Velocity is supposed to be zero let us
minus Omega a sign or make a t plus fi
but t is zero so that tells
me zero is minus Omega.
A signed Phi Omega is not,
zero is not zero.
That four signed five zero that
means five zero you get rid of that.
So the subsequent motion is x
equal the five core sine Omega t.
This is a problem we had.
We did not need fi,
but it could have been that
when you join the experiment,
you are somewhere here than
the masses actually moving.
Then I would say at d equals zero
velocity was some other number, maybe six.
Then you've got to go back and
write two equations. One Fedex,
take the date of it. Dude, it looks
like this and instead of putting zero,
you put six, you've got
two unknowns, a and Fi,
you've got to juggle them around.
You've got to solve for a and
five given these two numbers,
simple exercise to solve
for them and when you do,
you have completely fit the problem.
In other words,
simply to be told,
a mass is connected to the spring of
[inaudible] mass enforced constant.
It's not enough to determine the future
of the spray. You have to be told,
for example, if nobody pulled the mass,
it just want to sit there forever.
If you pulled it by 10 it's going to go
back and forth from 10 to minus 10 so
you have to be told further information
to nail down these two numbers.
They're called free parameters and
the solution on the other hand,
no matter how much you pulled
it and Javiera listed this
Omega and therefore the
frequency are not variable.
Yes,
any time start it.
If you started at rest,
indeed it will be zero because the
velocity at t equals zero is minus Omega a
sign fi do you want to kill that?
The only way is by equal to zero.
You could put five with the pie if you
like, but if you put zero that'll do.
Okay,
so
this is the elementary parts of this
thing and I already told you the following
things.
If x of t is equal to a cause,
Omega t let's put Phi equals zero in
other words it'd be like agree that since
there's only one oscillator it is perverse
to set your clock to zero at any time
other than when the oscillator
is at one extreme point.
If there are two oscillators
oscillating out of step,
it's impossible to make five zero for
both of them because if you can sync your
clock when one of them said the maximum,
that may not be when the other one said
at maximum but with one oscillator but
she was fine other than zero is perverse.
It's like saying I'm doing
a project title problem.
I'll pick the place where the line to
predict tile to be x equal to y equals
zero you can pick some other crazy origin
but it doesn't help so we'll assume
fire zero in this problem.
If that is x,
what is velocity at time t take the data
to with this you get minus Omega a sine
Omega t
that means the is also isolating.
Sane is finally, but the amplitude
for Oscillation is Omega Times a.
So a is the range of variation for
x we'll make at time say is that the
intubation for velocity. Lastly,
we'll go all the way through.
Plus Omega I minus Omega a,
the acceleration,
which is one more bit of it too is minus
Omega squared. A cost to make a tea,
which is really minus
Omega Square Times exit. So
so the amplitude for isolation for the
accelerations Omega squared times eight,
so I think you should understand
if will make us very large,
they end the velocity will have very
big excursions and the acceleration will
live even bigger excursions because the
range of this AI really means if you
plot x is going to look like this going
from a two minus eight this is if you
plot the velocity is
going to look like this.
The and we'll go from
Omega a minus Omega a.
If you plot the acceleration will go
from Omega squared eight to minus Omega
squared away.
Last thing you want to verify is
the law of conservation of energy.
I think I mentioned this Dubai and I
studied energy but let me repeat one more
time.
If you take in this problem,
one half NBS where plus
one half k x square.
I did that for you. You
can also verify this. Okay.
Uh,
one half k x squared is going
to involve [inaudible] squared.
Omega t one half MV squared is going
to involve something, something,
something science where Omega t and by
magic the science squared and costs and
squared will have the same coefficient.
So you can use the identity to set that
equal to one and get an answer that does
not depend on time.
That's the beauty.
Even though position and velocity are
constantly changing, this combination,
if you crank it out,
will not depend on time.
And what can it possibly be
if it doesn't depend on time.
I can calculate it whenever I like.
So let me go to the incident.
When the mass is reached one extremity
and this our board to swing back at that
instant,
it has no velocity.
It's only has an x which is
equal to the amplitude of motion.
So that's the energy of an isolator.
One half k square.
When x is when V is equal to zero x,
it'll be plus or minus a or
any other intermediate point.
You can find the velocity. If you
could give me the x, we did that too.
So this is all I want to say
about the linear oscillator.
Well,
let me mention to you another kind of
oscillation which is very interesting.
The subways,
you suspend a rod from
the ceiling like this.
It's sagging that if you give it a twist
then it'll go twisting back and forth
like that.
That's also simple harmonic motion except
watch wedding with time is not linear
coordinate, but the angle taper by
which that artists being twisted.
What's the equation in this case
equation here is I need to take over d d
square. You guys remember?
No, that's the analog of m a.
That's going to be equal to the torque.
Okay.
Now what will happen in the problems we
consider is if data is a small number
in the torque will be such that it
brings you back to today equals to zero.
So this number will be approximately
equal to minus some number kappa times
state.
Yeah,
just the analog of Buenos Kx
little k was the restoring force divided
by the displacement which produced a
distorting force.
Literally Kappa is the starting torque
divided with the angle at which you
twisted it to get that torque.
So this isn't always true
for small oscillations.
Since towel vanishes that
[inaudible] equal to zero,
it will look like some number
of times data if you like.
It's the tailor CDs for
Tau for small angles.
Yeah.
If you knew this kappa,
you are done because mathematically this
equation is the same as MD two x over
Dt squares minus Kx Good Omega for this
guy will be square root of kappa over
the eye.
You can steal the whole answer because
mathematically mathematicians don't care
if you're talking about data.
If you're talking about ex, uh,
if you compare this equation and this
equation MD two x over detainee square,
you pulled the minus kappa minus Kx.
If the Omega there was
root of k over them,
the Omega here will be
route of kappa over I.
So you may be thinking what,
give me an example where told
looks like capital times status.
So I'm going to give you that example.
So that example is going to be
the following. A simple pendulum
take a pendulum like this. It's
got a mass m, it's got some length.
L is hanging from the ceiling.
They said rigid rod, not a string,
but a rigid massless rod
and the mass numbers at the bottom.
So it's happy to hang like this,
but suppose you give it a kick
so you push it over there,
do an angle theta,
which is whatever you like.
What is the Torque in
this particular case,
let's find out the force is AMG
and the angle between the forest and
you're trying to do rotations around this
point.
This angle here is the same data.
So torque is really
minus m g l science data.
That's the formula for Torque is the
force times the distance of the lever arm
or the distance over which you,
the forces from the rotation axis
times the sine of the angle between the
direction of the force and the
direction of the separation.
So the equation of
motion for the pendulum,
but it really is the
following I need to take over.
D D Square is equal to
minus N G L sine theta.
No, we cannot do business
with this equation. This
equation is a famous equation,
but you and I don't know how
to solve it with what we know.
But we have learned even earlier today.
Look at the formula for scion x saying
next begins with x minus x cubed over
three factorial and so on.
So if data is small venue midnight,
there's AMG l data.
So for small angles,
scientists data in the restoring torque
in fact is linear in the coordinate,
the angular coordinate.
So by comparison,
now we know that this fellow is Sour
Kappa Kappa far the pendulum is MGL.
So cap,
I may not be universal in every problem.
In each problem you got to find kappa.
You find that by moving the system,
offer equilibrium, finding the restoring
torque. And if you're doing it right,
they're starting. Torque will always
look like something, something,
something time state everything.
Multiplying data is our kappa.
So let's know,
calculate Omega.
What does simple pendulum I'm showing you.
This is kappa over I and Kappa was what?
M G L and what's I?
Okay.
It's equal to moment to finish your of
this mass out on this point that artists
massless for the single point mass.
We know the moment of inertia
has just an times elsewhere.
Do you find Omega is equal to the square
root of g or what l and that is two Pi
over t so you get back.
The famous formula I learned Ti
is two Pi Square root of l over g.
This is the audit done up.
The formula you learn in school,
it comes from small
oscillations of a pendulum.
So think about this problem.
If you pull the pendulum by an angle,
so a large, that scientist has
no longer approximated but data,
but you need a that you
build with a six term,
it can happen for large enough data.
Then the equation to
solve is no longer this.
And what that means is if
you took a real pendulum
massless rod and a Bob at the end,
the time it takes to finish in isolation
in fact will depend on the amplitude.
The only for small oscillations when
synthetic can be approximated. But data,
you will find whether you'd do that
oscillation or that oscillation.
The time is the same.
But if you go too far,
the other terms in scientists that will
kick in and the result is no longer true.
It a pendulum in fact is not just a
function of l and g also function or the
amplitude only for small amplitudes.
You get this marvelous resolve.
This one problem I want you to
think about. Uh, I may do it myself.
[inaudible] I think you should try to
read up on it and I will try to explain it
next time,
which is the following.
I will give the problem to you and
I will do it for you next time.
I want you to think about it.
Here's a hoop,
like a hula hoop is hanging on the wall
with a nail and there's very happy to be
wedded to this. Now I come and give it
a little push. You'll start oscillating,
look like that and sometime
later it'll look like that.
It's going back and forth.
Your job is to find the
Omega for that Hoop.
Yeah.
So you move it a little bit and you find
the restoring Torque, then you're done.
But you got to do two things,
right? To get the right answer.
You've got to find a moment to finish.
You have a circular loop,
not around the center, but I don't
own a point on the circumference.
So you guys know the magic.
Where do you gotta use parallel axes?
Theorem and defined?
The restoring to here is the
part that blows everybody's mind,
was that when the loop goes to that
position, where does gravity acting?
Gravity's acting at the center of mass.
Center of mass is somewhere
here in the middle of the loop.
Even though there is no matter there.
So center of mass off a body
need not lay on the body.
That ring is a perfect example.
So if you remember,
the center of mass of the loop isn't
the center of the loop and put the AMG
there, you will get the right target
and everything will just fall.
Yeah.
By the way, my offer is always open.
If there's something about the class,
uh, you want to, and you find this hard,
does that you can always write to me,
okay,
you can,
I want your feedback because I just
don't know which parts that easy,
which parts are hard, which
are slow, which are fast.
Or if you haven't had enough
math and you need some help,
so send me some email and I
will try my best to answer that.